addition of Market takes we are breaking
down the latest U.S existing home sales
report and we're using that to talk
about the big picture in the U.S housing
market I got people calling me Dion
what's going on the housing markets is a
good time to buy a house we're going to
break that all down right here I am Dion
rabbon reporter for the Wall Street
Journal and we are going to dig deep
into today's U.S existing home sales
report there was a lot of really
interesting information it's going to
tell us a lot about the economy what's
been happening so far and maybe how
investors are viewing that information
to make moves in the market we're seeing
a lot of moves today so we are going to
talk through today what the existing
home sales report showed we're going to
of course talk about the overall state
of housing how the state of housing is
playing into expectations or worries
about inflation as well as how the
housing market is playing into
expectations and worries and fears about
a recession of course we're going to
check out the markets through
stocks bonds crypto FX Commodities
all that good stuff and then we're going
to tell you of course what to look out
for next because even though it's
backward looking data we are always
looking forward here on Market takes so
without further Ado let us jump into the
data now today's existing home sales
report showed that prices fell
unexpectedly we have seen here a real
consistent decline we've seen 12
straight months of declining overall
sales and we saw the the pace of sales
Fall to 4 million sales that's down
point seven percent from the previous
month but 37 year over year so sales are
slowing by 37 from where they were in
January 2022 and again that's the lowest
rate of sales since October 2010. so got
that chart up there just to kind of
illustrate where we have been on
existing home sales you see that just
precipitous decline in terms of the
number of home sale that that's not
exactly what's happening with the price
though so if you're looking for big
price declines the news not quite as
good as if you're just kind of betting
against the overall housing market now
expectations coming in economists have
predicted there would be 4.07 million
houses sold and a 1.5 increase so
economists were predicting that we would
reverse the overall decline that we had
seen for 11 straight months and that
existing home sales would creep up this
month just by a little bit by 1.5
percent we did not see this again
instead saw a 12th straight month of
declines in terms of the number of homes
sold that is the longest stretch since
1999. so existing home sales really the
number of homes just consistently
turning down and turning lower now when
we talk about price though on the other
hand the median price of a used home in
January was 359 thousand dollars that's
down from 366 500 uh just a little bit
about two percent decline but year over
year the median price price did pick up
by 1.3 so I want to put another chart up
here on your screen to just illustrate
what we've been seeing with prices this
is the percent change from a year before
so as we see as we're at the beginning
of your screen there on the left side
you see prices are increasing by about
15 16 around that 15 to 20 percent range
and you just see that pace decline
decline decline until we get to January
of this year when we saw just a 1.3
percent increase so again prices are
still increasing you're still seeing
overall existing home prep existing home
sales prices compared to a year before
continuing to rise but that pace is
decreasing and declining and we see up
here with this chart the illustration of
how that price growth has been declining
consistently that's not the overall
price that's just the increase in the
price declining from those big increases
that we saw 15 16 17 early on in last
year down to about 1.3 to start this
year so that's I think something to why
watch for as we could see outright year
over year decline something we have not
seen in the existing home sales report
for a very long time let's get into some
details because I know y'all come here
to nerd out with me we're going to know
just a little bit just a little we're
not going to go too far but I do want to
get into some of the details in the
report one really interesting thing that
I saw this was expected the days on the
market increased to 33. so we are now at
a point where the average existing home
is on the market for more than a month
that's big because we were a year ago
averaging 19 days now that was
historically low historically low number
of rates now we're getting back into
where if you list your home and go to
sell it it's going to be on the month
for about a month or over a month
average that's almost double the pace
that we saw in January 2022. inventory
is in the number of houses on the market
is still holding from that's about three
months 2.9 months but that is declining
from an increase in inventory that we
saw in 2022 so what I mean by that is
the inventory is just the number of
homes available for sale during 2020 and
2021 you saw that inventory just crash
and burn as fewer people were listing
their homes and those EX in the homes
that were on the market were just
getting snapped up really quickly so
there was a lot less supply of homes in
the market and there was a lot of demand
well in 2022 you saw Supply kind of
start to decrease and demand really
started to increase which was kind of
expected to even out those prices but
what we are seeing now demand is holding
steady you're still seeing high demand
but the supply is starting to level off
as people are saying oh well now's not a
good time to sell Builders are saying
now is not a good time to build and
you're seeing a leveling off and a
potentially decline of the inventory of
home sales on the market this is just
existing home sales so not new home
sales but basically the number of people
listing their home for sale is leveling
off at about three months worth of
inventory so another very interesting
piece of data I found in this report was
Cash sales have increased to 29 that
means almost not quite but almost one
out of every three homes sold has been
sold in cash that makes sense when
you're talking about a market where
interest rates have increased mortgage
rates are increased the overall price of
getting a mortgage has increased even
though prices have stopped increasing at
the same rate or at this very fast rate
they were but the overall price to buy
if you're a mortgager has increased but
if you're a cash buyer well now is
actually a great time because you're not
having to come in and fight over price
you're not getting you know 10 15 20
buyers trying to get that house in the
first day and if you've got cash well
you're probably paying a lower price
than you would have paid a year ago
versus someone who's getting a mortgage
now those cash buyers that's increased
to 29 of sales from 27 the month before
we're also looking at another
interesting stat the percentage of
first-time home buyers Rose to 31 of
sales from 27 as these rates have
climbed up Folks at the National
Association of Realtors have worried
about existing or first-time buyers
being priced out of the market a lot of
those people on the lower end income
Spectrum have been priced out but we're
seeing now an increase and that was that
increased in December as well and you
saw another increase in January to 31
almost a third of the sales coming from
first-time home buyers uh that's big and
this number of sales to investors and
those big companies you're about KKR you
hear about Blackstone all these
companies coming in and buying sales
well that number decreased to 16 from 22
a year before so we're seeing more
first-time home buyers more folks buying
in cash that usually means wealthy folks
people high net worth investors those
kinds of people they're buying a lot but
also first time home buyers people who
haven't owned a home before now this is
good in the in the sense that more
people are buying houses rather than
corporations we know in corporations buy
they like to jack those prices up when
they rent it out to folks and that kind
of saturates and moves the rental price
up so we're seeing things that could
suggest rent prices could be decreasing
but one thing if you're a market if
you're a market Watcher and you've been
watching the market for for a while one
thing you know is that we're seeing
retail investors move in what investors
professional money managers call the
dumb money is starting to get into the
real estate market and that's generally
a sign that uh the market might be
peaking out and it's time for smart
investors the smart money as they say to
get out because the dumb money is moving
in they usually buy at the top and sell
at the bottom historically speaking
we've seen some difference in change in
that over on the stock market as more
folks are getting educated but this
these numbers do suggest that we're
seeing Big Time investors move away
worried about some fears that the market
might be overheating that these
increases by the Federal Reserve are
going to crash the housing market while
we are seeing regular retail investors
so-called dumb money moving into the
market and buying that's generally not a
good sign if you're talking about asset
prices so let's take a step back now and
talk about the overall state of the
housing market we have seen declines
really across the board uh I want to
read a quick quote to you from
um Jeffries a note they put out today
they say quote the details of the report
suggest that housing is no longer a
seller's market until this summer home
prices continue to rise despite
declining demand likely because Supply
was so muted however the balance of
power is finally shifting from sellers
to buyers albeit slowly that slowly part
is a big thing because we could see this
balance of power actually shift back
because as I told you supply has really
kind of petered out and kind of
plateaued existing home sales is the
largest it's about 85 to 90 percent of
the overall housing market so this
report is the one to watch now prior to
this we saw housing start slow by 4.5
percent that was double what was
expected and down for the fifth month in
a row we also saw single-family home
building decline 27 on a year of year
basis in January we're seeing mortgage
applications decline basically a lot of
these things that could have been
getting better have actually been
getting worse on the housing market and
like we talked about those interesting
those interesting details that show it's
much more retail investors Mom and Pops
maybe just regular folks buying homes a
lot of them buying with cash though so
probably not you know Mom and Pop on
Becky down the street it's probably Aunt
Becky with the big bag buying a house
right now in Straight Cash
um this also plays into the big picture
which is that housing is slowing down
prices starting to move lower but still
increasing that's a trend to watch for
because overall in 2022 you saw that big
decline in housing we need to see that
continue for prices to really
meaningfully move lower when mortgage
rates are starting to pick back up and
we'll talk about what we're seeing in
the markets and how that relates to the
mortgage Market in just a second so the
role of Housing and overall inflation is
we're looking out at overall inflation
how housing plays a role in that I want
to throw up a chart of CPI the Consumer
Price Index here to just kind of
illustrate what we're seeing overall in
the market so inflation we're going back
about a year now you see that consistent
pickup until until that peak in June and
then prices have come down consistently
each month now as that has happened
we're seeing inflation come from that
nine percent level where it was in June
down to 6.4 percent which is where it
was in January of this year now in June
of last year that nine percent was the
highest we'd seen in around 40 years it
peaked up there and it's been coming
down but the pace has not been as fast
as a lot of folks would expect so as you
see those numbers still very high when
you compare it to historical long-term
averages when just five years ago the
U.S couldn't get to even two percent
inflation the Fed was worried that we
might have disinflation and that they
needed to do a lot more to simulate the
economy so this CPI chart kind of
illustrates that overall theme that we
had seen with the with the pace of
overall inflation listen approximately 9
out of 10 Metro markets registered price
gains in the fourth quarter of 2022.
that means prices are not going down
they're not declining we're not seeing
disinflation in the housing market
that was according to the National
Association of Realtors latest quarterly
report I want to read you a quick quote
from Nar Chief Economist Lawrence Yoon
he says a Slowdown in home prices is
underway and welcomed particularly as
the typical home price has risen 42
percent in the past three years that is
big now he's saying these increases have
far surpassed wage increases and
Consumer Price inflation since 2019. we
are seeing a decline of the pace of
housing price increases but prices still
going up even as the number of homes
sold is low that's not good if you're
trying to sell your house
it's not great if you're trying to buy a
house either if we're being honest we
have seen lower rents and some decline
in the housing price at housing asking
prices overall but not big declines
we're not seeing the housing market
crash except in terms of the number of
sales uh so let's talk about housing in
terms of the role of recession fears and
some of those worries that folks have
had about a U.S recession this report
certainly does nothing to alleviate any
of those fears if the housing market is
crashing that does a lot of damage to
the rest of the overall economy we're
seeing housing listen Mark mortgages are
a big piece of the overall borrowing
market and we have seen a huge increase
in borrowing but one thing that housing
does do is it provides a place for folks
to borrow cheaply so if you want to get
a home equity loan or home equity line
of credit or you want to pull money from
your house in one of those ways that's a
much cheaper way to borrow money than if
you have to get a personal loan if you
have to go out and get a property a
title loan something like that or borrow
from your credit card well we are seeing
those housing prices as those decline as
folks are less excited about giving big
loans out for folks borrowing against
their mortgage that means folks are
going to have to turn to other sources
of borrowing because we've seen those
savings buffers are getting just wiped
out consumer the personal savings rate
for Americans right now is down around
three percent even lower some of the
lowest levels of consumer saving that we
have seen in decades right now and so
folks those saving buffers that they
built up during the during the the
recession the Pandemic those have been
really wiped out and people are kind of
on their last legs and they're starting
to borrow a lot of money Consumer Credit
Rose by 33 billion dollars in November
and 11.6 billion dollars in December
those are big numbers and so home equity
lending and mortgage borrowing is a big
piece of those overall borrowing numbers
but we are seeing a lot of consumers
turn towards credit cards and borrowing
on their credit card whether that's
taking a loan or just putting things on
their credit card they can't afford to
buy right now
um personal loans title loans all those
have picked up and we are seeing an
increase in delinquencies we're seeing
folks fall behind and being unable to
make their payment that's adding to some
of these recession fears and recession
worries because folks are not really
able to the way if your house had risen
a hundred thousand dollars in value last
year well now that increase is only
fifty thousand dollars because the value
of your home is is falling because
prices aren't increasing as fast and so
people aren't able to borrow maybe they
they say okay well I can only borrow and
remember you can only borrow a
percentage of the equity that you've got
and you're having to borrow at higher
rates now that's a lot less attractive
for some people and they're having to
turn to some of these other methods or
they are turning to some of these other
methods for borrowing that cost a lot
more to be paid back this also hits into
housing companies Home Furnishings uh
things like places like Target Walmart
we saw just this morning Home Depot
guiding lower on in its earnings call
and their stock taking a big hit was
down five percent early on in the market
today and if as they forecast an
earnings decline that also at companies
like low housing plays a big part in the
overall economy because when people buy
a new house they don't just buy the
house they buy stuff to put in the house
they buy some paintings they invite
their friends over they have parties all
those things if those things aren't
happening because people aren't buying
houses as we've seen with the overall
pace of housing purchases well that puts
a dent and some worry in the overall
economy that can pick up these recession
fears and that might be why we're seeing
what we're seeing in the stock market so
as we look out at the overall market
right now we are seeing the stock market
down in a big way the S P 500 is down
about 1.6 percent and the Dow uh the
NASDAQ down about two percent we are
seeing bond yields up in a major way
we're seeing the 10-year note of about
10 basis points up to about four point
almost four percent it's about 3.92
right now on the 10-year yield the
currencies you're seeing the dollar rise
it's up against the Euro by about 2.25
up across the board except against the
British pound watch the British pound if
you're in the currency markets that's
definitely the one to watch and in the
coming days we're seeing crypto down by
about two to three percent across the
board Bitcoin down about 1.4 percent
Commodities one interesting thing to
note we are seeing natural gas just nose
diving it's down at a low uh this is the
lowest natural gas has been in quite
some time going back on wsj.com we're
seeing Nat gas down the lowest in more
than a year it's it's heading towards
that two dollar Mark and that is a huge
huge area of resistance you're going to
want to watch Nat gas at that two dollar
Mark uh copper though up in a big way
copper AKA Dr copper a well-known
indicator of the US economy up about 2.6
percent today has been what has been
rising for quite some time definitely
watch copper so listen what comes next
here's what we're looking at the fomc
minutes the minute from the latest fed
meeting come out tomorrow we'll be
watching those very carefully because
investors aren't very curious what the
FED thinks about all this new data the
new home sales report is out on Friday
as well as the universe University of
Michigan consumer sentiment index we
have seen big increases in that report
lately we'll see if that continues if
consumers continue to feel good as gas
prices keep falling and on March 1st
that's a couple weeks from now or sorry
about a week from now
don't worry we're coming back here on
Market takes we will be talking about
the global manufacturing PMI talking
about the state of the global economy
businesses and how they are doing
overall globally we will be breaking all
that down right here on Market takes on
March 1st on March 1st listen I know you
can be anywhere in the world you were
here with me today I hope you'll be with
me again on March 1st when we do it
right here on Market takes listen that's
going to do it for today's edition of
Market takes I am Dion ravone reporter
at the Wall Street Journal I hope you'll
be with us next time